This whole discussion has been a little abstract.
So now I want to show you one of my favorite uses of PCA in the wild.
And that's facial recognition.
So first let's think about what makes facial recognition in pictures a,
a good application of PCA.
Why is this problem and the solution well suited for each other.
Here are some options and the answer could be one or more of the following.
The first option is that pictures of faces generally have
a high input dimensionality.
In other words if there's many pixels in a picture of a face.
And that potentially any of those pixels could be important for
figuring out who that person is.
The second possibility is that faces have general patterns that could be
captured in a smaller number of dimensions.
So there's always the general pattern that someone has two eyes that are sort of
near the top of their face.
There's a, a mouth and then a chin that's on the bottom, and etcetera.
And the third possibility is that facial recognition is simple,
once you use machine learning.
That since humans can do it so easily, a computer can do it easily too.